you're welcome to this video video about
an opening yes but let me in gambit
yeah funny opening that quite often is
some yeah but it's requested in my live
streams that I should play that and
sometimes stride sometimes even with
success but this video will actually now
show how to refute that opening I think
it can be useful for you for players to
watch because well it's a rare opening
but sometimes it's it's played and in
blitz and and and other quicker time
control them can tell control events and
it's useful to know how it's reviewed it
because it's simply it's easy to do I
just have to have to know very little
but if you know it you can refute it I'm
going to show you all you need to know
to get a great position against the
Latvian on a general note I'd like to
tell you that I'm going to do more
videos on openings in the future mostly
not very long videos but videos that
would present a certain concept of a
certain idea or like here like a quick
fix that you might be able to use if you
want some information ok what what am i
doing if the guy actually plays the
Latvian can watch that video and get a
quick information on that I'm urging
other opening content that I had done
earlier into one opening playlist will
have opening disasters openings
uncovered and I think I also did
something on the London system one once
it's kind of merged together yeah I also
did those larger repertoire series on
deform ID for those are good remains
separate because they make sense as a as
a block but the other videos I'm going
to merge into into one opening playlist
so let's get going here the Latvian it's
e4 e5 Knight f3 f5 yeah not the most
logical move ever black yeah gives away
pants and weakens his King and the
process it's like a Kings gambit
a temple down and the Kings gambit is
not that brilliant in the first place
the important thing is to really know
one line against it and I think the best
line is 90 85 i I looked at this really
and try to find out what is best and
there are a couple of other moves that
don't impress that much for example I
move like Bishop c4 which looks quite
logical can be answered by by this weird
continuation where Queen age 5 check
looks like it wins but it is not that
clear actually yeah after g6 I don't
really want to go into what is not so
great I just want to show what's good
because that's all you need to know II
don't really know to know in detail why
the other moves are not that great so
Knight takes d5 is right here black
plays Queen to f6 this is the only move
that is played with some frequency
there's the move knight c6 that
sometimes played that move seems to be
entirely incorrect actually but it's
still sometimes played um here white has
a very comfortable choice if you want a
very easy life you can just take that
and play deform and that just better
your pawn up and there's not a single
hint of compensation for black you can
take yeah but it's not a good idea as
the shine uses the rook and on Queen h5
you definitely don't want to play King
d7 I mean you have to in that case rook
down is even worse but anyway d4 is
completely fine if you really want to
refute that you can play an h5 that
seems to be very good for what
but it's um it's kind of murky this kind
of thing takes takes Queen e7 and why
there's an exchange up and two pawns but
it is still kind of murky and this is
the best line and it seems that white is
probably a much much better it's the
kind of situation that a computer and
engine would win 100% of the time but
for human it's it's debatable if you
want to go with this or if you want to
play that
that simple move d4 yeah just take it
and play d4 and you are a pawn up and
have a better position so it's really
good enough the other thing is for those
guys who really want to play em yeah
Queen h5 the the hardest possible way
but Queen f6 is the main move here is an
interesting moment again where white I
think can give up a little bit of
prospects for an advantage the best move
is night C for this is stronger than D
for D for it's not bad at all I mean
like this sit back here and this white
is also better in this position but one
important thing is that if you have the
points like that d4 and e4 wide opening
up the position won't happen that
quickly white can play this Bishop
Castle f3 and try to open up but if you
play Knight c4 here instead like here
you still have the idea to play d3 at
some point and we will see more of that
and that will open up the center very
quickly black takes it it's no real
other move and 93 we see that white is
gaining you Chum huge lead in
development here already it's difficult
for black to to take care of that about
that pawn
yeah it is attacked what is black doing
him and funny enough and the most
popular movie is giving up that pawn and
playing c6 yeah and the reason is that
the other moves yeah
even worse and let's have a look there's
also Queen moves yeah quite quite quite
clearly I'm sorry um I'm sorry I'm
confusing things Queen f7 is the main
move here should look at the other Queen
oc6 is one move later I'm sorry yeah
let's start with this Queen g6 that's
the first move to cover you for ya what
to do here the simple recipe is always
go d3 we open up the position and asked
like questions about that pawn if black
takes it
yeah like takes here while we recapture
and we see that White's development
advantage is getting enormous yeah and
why keep and I can take here just to
show check-in age 5 King moves percent
before yeah where's this going
it's just a big joke yeah because white
has everything development black nothing
so that's not not going to work at all
so ticks ticks 93 that was Queen g6 you
played d3 that's the key move and all
you need to know that's always d3 coming
if black I was queen is six you'll go 93
first and now have Bishop c4 in the in
the mix and again d3
yeah like c6 oops I'm sorry c6 you're go
d3 and why this much better Liam if
black takes we're going to recapture and
well you already see week we are going
to castle and black has only move the
screen around and weekend is king white
has three pins pieces out already this
is probably going to be a very quick end
to the game yeah just to give an idea if
you give that a name [ __ ] it's just like
plus three yeah so the engine already
sees that this is going to be a total
disaster in them in the near future so
black mostly plays Queen f7 in this
position the ideas that Knight takes e4
is answered by the d5 fork so this is to
be avoided but the recipe is simple
again you go Knight e3 that's a strong
move we threaten Bishop c4 him and still
have the d3 possibility of our sleeves
yeah if black goes Knight f6 year we
play Bishop c4 note that we control d5
so much that this is not even possible
so Queen back to g6 and then not back it
never been there but well it feels like
the Queen is is just hopping around and
then d3 and again we are opening up the
position and
have a fantastic lead in development
yeah Glenn takes yeahjust and castles
Ruki 1 this is the end gem so it's
already a winning position for white
it's not better even that's probably
going to be a win because black cannot
castle and I mean if he tries let's say
c6 go rook e1 Bishop e7 Bishop d3 Queen
95 and that's it
yeah it's going to be a real real quick
quick and painful end to that game the
relatively best continuation and that
tells you quite a bit about the quality
of that opening is that black plays c6
in this position the idea is to go d5
and cover the pawn however white can
just capture only for an alternative is
d3 here again that's rather logical but
in this particular case after d5 like is
indeed threatening deform and you don't
have a very convincing move against that
yeah you can try to sacrifice that piece
because well d4 Bishop c4 but black has
something like Bishop c5 let's say and
you don't have a very clear way to
exploit this now you know maybe you can
sacrifice on the fire Fayed is so
dangerous so d3 is not bad but I
recommend just to take the pawn yeah if
you take the pawn there's really nothing
that black and show for it he goes d5
there this has been played in a couple
of games amazingly enough I really
wonder what kind of person would go for
that
it's black you just really important for
nothing it should be six and d4 yeah
this is just a pawn for absolutely
nothing and White has clear clear ideas
Bishop to d3 possibly c4 attacking the
d5 pawn this is just just excellent for
white and you have a choice there
instead of grabbing the pawn with a good
position you can over also try the three
which however I didn't thought to be
that clear yeah it still looks it looks
good but yeah maybe I'm too much of
materialistic player I just think okay
I'll take the pawn and then better so
why why not just do it it scores
excellently and white erm what can be
very very uncomfortable here with that
pawn so to sum that up against the net
Vienna gambit you take only five with
the noid not grabbing f5 or Bishop c4
other moves take that pawn knight c6
seems to be incorrect
due to PES D both moves knight c6 or
queen h5 and after Knight f6 you go to C
form speed up development and now you
only have to check if you want to take
that pawn under which circumstance or
when you want to go d3 that's the
difference really to this move as I as I
said here you have the pawn already on
d4 so that d3 is not possible anymore
to open up the position quickly in here
again here that's also better for white
but I think the the other line that I
showed as your as a main recommendation
with Knight c4 is better because you
develop quicker and you get the
positioned position opened up in a much
clearer much clearer way yeah your
choices basically have a fantastic
position with no material up or get a
pawn and black has no compensation for
that so fantastic opening result yet
hope you like that video I have it's
certainly helpful in some cases it's not
played off in the Latvian but I mean I
tried that out a couple of times in my
live streams and I had some title
players who really reverse after the
opening they they didn't know any of
that and I find that pretty pretty
amazing because while you looked you
look at that once and then you're
basically a gaining point after point if
someone really plays it against you even
though it's clear it's not a frequent
opening okay well I hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching